[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster
i'm constantine kissing and this is the
show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
our incredible guest today is a former
member of al qaeda who then became spy
for mi6
heyman dean welcome to trigonometry
thank you for having me
it's a pleasure to have you here listen
man what a fascinating background
a lot of people are going to be like
whoa let's let's listen to this guy
i one thing i should probably mention is
you're the co-host of the conflicted
podcast
uh and your co-host uh thomas small we
had on the show
one probably one of our most fascinating
interviews that we've ever done
talking about the middle east and all
that sort of thing so before we get into
the interview which is going to be
absolutely fantastic i can't wait
just give everybody a little bit more of
the flavor of your background
how are you where you are what's been
your journey because it sounds like an
incredible one
um okay i will try to condense it into
one minute uh so
so you can say basically that i am a
saudi born and raised
uh bahraini um half lebanese and there
are
you know turkish and persian and other
ethnicities there it's
you know middle eastern salad really um
and so
from saudi arabia i grew up there pretty
much a religious
um in a young lad um you know memorized
the quran at a young age
wanted basically to become an imam um
but
much to the relief of my would-be
congregation
i didn't you know end up being an imam i
ended up
uh joining the jihad in bosnia when i
was 16.
there basically the journey started
towards darker and darker motives
you know and uh in 1997 i ended up
joining al qaeda in afghanistan
um they sent me to their program for
wmd including explosives chemical
weapons biological weapons and
i was trained on that um and then uh
there was a moment of disillusionment
um after the east africa bombings uh
when
al-qaeda targeted american embassies in
nairobi and darussalam in tanzania
um i just couldn't uh continue with the
group and i decided i want to leave
uh through the process of leaving i
ended up basically in the lab of the
british intelligence services um who
um you know well it was supposed to be
six months the briefings uh ended up
basically eight years of espionage
inside al qaeda um
in 2006 um through the wisdom of
some american administration officials
they leaked my identity to a
journalist in the us um because they
wanted
to talk about the successes uh they had
in terms of espionage against al-qaeda
even though i wasn't their spy i was the
british but then
you know vassal state you know all of
that
um and so um i
of course basically had to uh leave the
uh service of the british intelligence
agencies and i
ended up basically exchanging one form
of terrorism to another i became a
banker
well seriously i was a banker
so i joined the offices of um
a global uh bank looking after
issues related to terrorism finance well
and of course basically looking into uh
issues of security
uh geopolitical uh stability um
and after that basically i left to work
for even more evil
organizations is the oil industry um and
uh
yeah you know basically to this day i
still work as a consultant for
uh the energy industry as well as for
you know other governments
you know and some other evil entities so
yeah that's
really my life in a nutshell so a minute
of
summarizing the life of immorality of
avery
i suppose i suppose the question we want
to ask in who's got more
psychopaths your industry banking or
al-qaeda
difficulties
well fantastic i would say i would say
the i would say that the banking
industry got its fair share of
psychopaths for sure
absolutely weapons of mass destruction
well
we're joking around and of course it's
it's it's a fascinating
uh story condensed very briefly you talk
about it in great detail on the conflict
conflicted podcast which i recommend
everybody to listen to
it's just incredible how good how good
it is
um but let's talk a little bit about
some of the stuff that particularly
interests and affects people here in the
west uh
which is uh you know i it
never really made too much sense to me
kind of logically looking at it why
a guy who grows up in in you know in
london or in bradford or whatever it
might be
might want to become so extreme in their
thinking that they would go and fight
and die in in syria or in afghanistan or
in iraq in your case it was
going from bahrain to bosnia i mean i
don't know much about bahrain but i
imagine living in bahrain was better
than that
fighting and dying in bosnia right so
like that
that kind of you know why do people
become
extremists why do people become
islamists why are they willing to die
and leave the prosperity and the comfort
and the freedoms
of the west and go and do this kind of
thing i think that's a question that
would
that puzzles all of us in some ways
doesn't it
well there are i mean i mean the answer
to this could take us
several podcasts and several interviews
just basically to get into the depth of
it
you've got five minutes mate
welcome to the mainstream media raymond
you know i faced worse challenges before
yes
all i can tell you if i want to condense
it
is that there are several layers of
uh reasons one of them basically is
identity crisis
where people basically you know cease to
identify with their own
you know immediate society one of one of
the questions i always get asked by
people
is that you know why there is a war
between islam and the west and
you know and which is basically this is
a narrative that is prevalent
uh out there i always say that there
isn't
and there isn't a war between islam and
the west there is a war within islam
itself there is a civil war within islam
in which pitting the people who believe
in the modern nation state
against people who don't believe in the
modern nation state
this is really what's happening the
forces of the modern nation states right
now in the middle east basically are
fighting for survive for survival for
their own survival
against transnational ideologies like
the
muslim brotherhood like sunni militant
islam
like al-qaeda and isis and shabab like
the political and militant uh shia islam
the light of the day system or the
ayatollahs of the quran and their allies
like hezbollah
and the yemen all of these forces are
trying to bring down the nation state
now why i'm saying that this is related
to identity crisis because
the uh you know we shape our own
identity
you know around the modern nation state
you know you're all british i mean
basically i would
describe myself as british now because
basically i believe my allegiance is to
this state
to this modern nation state and
therefore basically i have
allegiance to this nation state these
people who have identity crisis
is because they have ceased to believe
in the modern nation state and started
to believe in transnational ideologies
that want to bring down the modern
nation state and create an empire
in our bubble so just to pause you just
for one moment and
there's plenty more time i was only
joking when i said you only have five
minutes
just to put it in simple language for
people what you're really talking about
is
someone growing up in bradford let's say
but not actually feeling british
uh they they don't feel british they
don't feel an allegiance to this country
what they really feel is
they are part of a movement whose job it
is
to let's say recreate the caliphate for
example just as an example exactly
exactly this is exactly what it is the
idea is that
there is a you know this romantic
vision of imperial islamic past that
need to be resurrected
and that's the only way basically
muslims can feel uh
strengthened and emboldened and
empowered which is
you know far away from the truth the
truth is basically that there is a lot
of romanticization
of islamic history which misled many
young people into believing that the
past is so glorious that the only way
forward is to repeat that past
with all its false and shortcomings
mostly hidden
uh because of the way we teach history
unfortunately
and as a result you have people who
basically seems to believe
in their own uh nation state whether
adopted or even
their origin original nation state uh
from their countries of origin and as a
result they start to believe
that what al qaeda is telling what isis
is telling
what the iranian revolutionaries are
selling
is the future and as a result they flock
into these conflicts
because they believe that by recreating
the caliphate they will restore
islamic glory um and
this is where you know you have the
other side of muslims
who say no we have a functioning modern
nation state
and this is the best guarantee for
security safety stability law and order
uh prosperity why do we have to abandon
this
a vehicle for peace just only basically
to pursue a dream
that will end up and result in oceans of
blood and mountains of skulls
so identity crisis is the first
step towards that dark path you know
people don't believe anymore
in their nation states and end up
believing in transnational ideologies
so just on that on that aim and let's
just go before francis
he's got a whole different other things
that he wanted to talk to you about but
just we stick with that for a moment
just summarizing what you've said there
is it fair to say then
that the identity crisis and and
the temptation that some young muslims
in the west feel
and not only in the west but also in the
middle east and elsewhere
feel to join these these organizations
these extremist organizations
is a failure of integration uh in the
west
is that fair to say and and a failure
perhaps of
what has been kind of described as
multiculturalism but basically the idea
that
rather than us all becoming british or
us all being american
under one nation state what we are is
communities
you got you got the asian community this
community
that community which are not encouraged
to to become
british in a way uh they encouraged to
think of themselves as being still kind
of in in the space from which they came
this is one of the um
inaccuracies i would say of
the narrative that has been pushed by
some academics unfortunately
to say that it's the failure of
integration that
led to people becoming more or less
disillusioned to the point of joining
terrorist organizations if that is the
case
why would thousands of young saudis
algerians and tunisians
can't even integrate into their own
societies
you know even though they lived there
with their gender you know for you know
100 generations before
it's really not that simple it's not
like about alienation it's a fact that
people just divorcing themselves
from the concept and the institution of
the nation state
it's it's really that simple but why are
they doing that aim and that's what i'm
trying to get at
but then we have to reach into the we
start to depart now
the rational into the irrational
we will we will unfortunately depart you
know be in the realm of the
rationality into the realm of
irrationality
when we start to talk about the fact
that they
have also the religious and spiritual
element here
we can't talk about you know islamic
inspired terrorism without talking about
islam itself
um you know we'll be kidding ourselves
and by the way before anyone you know
start saying basically anything i mean
i'm a devout muslim myself
you know i you know uh not a day goes by
without without me reciting the quran
and saying my prayers so
please like i mean do not uh think for a
moment i'm attacking my own religion
here i'm just basically
trying to dissect objectively
you know why people end up
misinterpreting
everything basically they read and then
they go and commit acts of terrorism
um the reality is that irrationality
takes hold here
islam we have to understand is
just like catholicism is a guilt-based
religion uh
it means basically that you feel guilty
about so many things you do
uh you know and therefore you know islam
regulated the relationship between the
individual
and the creator uh through three
channels or three pillars
these pillars of worship are
love hope and fear so you
love the lord you okay so you you know
so basically
you apologize okay so
i hope this is this isn't someone coming
for you to shut you down that's like
youtube going
shut this [ __ ] down he's talking about
islam
no no no no so so basically um
you have three pillars of worship here
which is love fear and hope
love for the lord hope for his reward
and
fear of his eternal damnation it's
supposed to be balanced like you know
you know
so in a sentence basically that you love
the lord you hope for his reward but you
fear his eternal damnation
that is how balance the relationship
between me
between me and god for example should be
however because of the advent of
globalization
uh over the past generation many clerics
across the muslim world
decided to rely on fear and the
preaching of
fear and the aspects of fear within
islam in order to deter their
congregations
from indulging in acts that are
sinful uh whether drinking sleeping
around
consumption and selling of drugs and all
these other things joining gangs
and that was more prevalent actually in
the west also but it was equally
practiced in
the arab world and the muslim world in
general so
you end up basically with the
balance of preaching in crisis because
the preachers are using fear
which drives people into guilt which
drives them into looking for
solutions and one of the solutions is
looking for redemption and redemption is
in jihad and martyrdom
according to groups like isis and
al-qaeda and other
nefarious groups they want to recruit
people who they basically believe that
the only way they can redeem
themselves of sins is through jihad and
martyrdom you see
we don't have a priesthood in islam
where they can't absolve you of your
sins if you confess
unlike catholicism so therefore we have
this crisis in in in how
religious principles being transmitted
to young people in friday prayers
where they feel that okay if you drink
hell if you smoke hell if you take drugs
hell if you sleep around hell
there isn't that message of hope that if
you refrain from all of this you will
end up going to heaven god will reward
you
uh with a heavily abode forever and ever
you know so basically this crisis in
religious preaching resulted in
many people becoming more and more
guilty now that is not enough yet
to push them over the edge but then
comes the even more rational
which is prophecies you know
all jihadists who join the
jihadist groups whether they are isis
al-qaeda al-shabab
uh or even more so
hezbollah and the houses in yemen and
the
iranian irgc they are all motivated by
prophecies of a
awaited messiah a mahdi as they call him
the idea that
there will be these black banners rising
from afghanistan and eastern iran
you know marching all the way towards
jerusalem slaughtering all the jews and
basically
ushering in an era of a new caliphate
you have
you know these prophecies talking about
great wars in afghanistan and north
africa in syria and iraq and yemen
um all of these are being
packaged even though they are all
fabrications from history
um you know but i i don't want to go
into details about that
um but they are fabrications if you look
deep into them however they are sold
like drugs like
you know spiritual intoxicants as i
would call them
which will then basically tell people
who already feel
sinful and in need of redemption
and they feel alienated in need of
belonging and empowerment
and on top of all of this they already
have this identity crisis they need to
be part of a purpose
that you have a destiny you can free
your your own
inner sadist inner violent individual
to go and fight for god in order to
fulfill
a a a blueprint for a war
ordained fourteen hundred years ago it
it
it's intoxicating for many people and
that's why
we know many academics are still baffled
about why prisons in particular
you know are a fertile brand because
that's where the
most guilty consciences live that's
where
most downtrodden people are and that's
where people basically who have
inner sadism and violence that need to
be you know
released and eamonn how does the process
work for a lot of these people who get
indoctrinated
in this kind of mentality is it that you
know that they go to a particular type
of mosque is it a preacher
is it normally a family friend how does
it work normally
there isn't a single methodology i mean
it could be peer
you know peer-to-peer um this is one uh
popular method
um and it would be through social media
uh in the in the past it used to be
through either mosques or universities
um and then it became mosques
universities and prisons
uh now it is mosques universities
prisons peer-to-peer and social media
uh all coming together basically you
know and you know in the past basically
if i wanted to recruit someone i would
have to go
uh to a mosque or a islamic society in a
university
now these days you know i could
basically record the video
and i could invade a hundred thousand
you know
personal phones bedrooms and living
rooms
and preach my message um i don't need
even to be alive
i could record many things i could write
many things like people like anwar
lahuwalate for example
um the famous english speaking alpine
the preacher
and leave them there you know for
eternity you know online uh keeping
people being recruited so
the the thing that i found very
interesting and incredibly worrying was
when i was reading some of your articles
was you saying how incredibly difficult
it is
to de-radicalize people who have been
indoctrinated
um one of the things that
people need to understand is that
once you go down the path of believing
that you are fulfilling a divine destiny
that's going to end up empowering people
if you believe that the world is run by
a cabal of corrupt
you know bloodthirsty creeps and that
your mission is to pave the way for a
messiah-like figure
to come along then you have already
gone down too far down the path of
irrationality
to bring them back the problem is is
that
the spiritual aspect of jihadism
and islamic inspired political violence
really you know take hold of the mind to
the point where people cannot believe
that everything they've done everything
they fought for everything they bled
was wrong um and to try
in you know and to try to tell them that
because you see the preaching
within jihadi circles jihadi camps
jihadi
you know online you know uh forums
you know really focus on taking you
upwards as if like you are spiritually
ascending
above what they call the mundane
realities of the world
you know you see your fellow humans as
nothing but cattle
you know they just live every day you
know basically mundane lives
they eat they graze you know they breed
you know they sleep no purpose in life
you however
that's what they tell you you however
have a far more divine purpose
you are far above them you see that's
why you know when people say
how could these people behead and
execute
uh other people without feeling any
sense of remorse and the
answer is because they have already gone
too far in their superiority complex
rising above everyone else in their
spiritual ascendance as they call it
to see everyone else below them as ants
that can be trodden on
and therefore basically they don't feel
the human connection
with their fellow human beings who are
not seeing a
you know what part of their ideology
so this is why how can you bring someone
down to earth
you tell them basically that okay can
you switch off
that spiritual uh part of your mind and
just switch on the logical and
irrational one to just
for a minute consider maybe everything
that you've heard
was either wrong or misinterpreted um
or basically it was a fabrication from
history that have seeped into the
books in which picked up in recent you
know decades by people who basically
have an agenda against the
modern nation state it's
extremely difficult to just switch off
that
you know ever buzzing spiritual engine
in their mind telling them that they are
on a divine
mission more like if if you ever watched
that uh
you know movie from the 1980s which was
one of my favorites
uh the blues brothers you know we are on
a mission from god
i'm gonna be honest you aiming i didn't
expect you to start talking about the
blues brothers mate i'm gonna be
there's a bit of a left field note there
but look here's a question so we're now
talking about the case of shamima began
with the 15 year old girl
um for those of you uh people who are
not from the uk it's a 50
year old girl who was radicalized went
to the caliphate to fight and support
isis
now wants to come back what did we do in
the cases of those people
who have declared themselves allies
believers all the rest of it
so how do we bring them back into
society
can we do it and also
what do we do with these people who are
identifying with this
way of life and belief system
if i know the answer to this i'll be
extremely rich man by now i mean
you've worked in the bank and for the
oil industry if you're not extremely
rich already you're doing something
seriously wrong man
um you know i would say you know okay
i would remove the extreme and just put
in keep the
you know the rich part okay so um i
would say
that it is extremely difficult
to extract them from that mentality and
to just to bring them back
uh into reality unless if they
themselves feel disillusioned
that's one and remember by that time i
mean she spent what five years now
um in that part of the world both as a
you know as a jihadi bride
as a militant possibly you know and uh
also as a prisoner
uh in that prison camp uh
she would be extremely apart from
damaged
especially if she lost three children um
apart from the fact that she would be
you know damaged mentally um
the question is how do you take her back
into believing that all the things that
you have seen around her all the friends
that she knew
are actually not destined to have him
but to hell
and that all of the people who you know
she had developed affinity to
were just mistaken as we call them you
know in islam the mistaken you know dogs
of hell
um how can you convince her of that i
mean it's
it needs to be done you know in a closed
in a confined you know comfortable space
um the question is do we have the will
or even the resources to do it do we
have the trains
you know personnel to do it um do we
have to spend millions and millions and
millions of taxpayer money
just basically trying to rehabilitate
people who are going to be extremely
difficult to rehabilitate
i mean it's you know i you know this is
why one of the
um uh statements by rory stewart
the former conservative minister and mp
he said
uh once and i supported him fully on
this he said
it's much kinder if they just die there
you know on in the war zone and just you
know be done with it just die there
and why i know and i know many people
will be shocked but
this is the islamic way to do it
actually this is exactly
why imam ali uh who was revered by both
shia and sunnis
uh he had to deal with the sect like
this the first breakaway sect in islam
was the khawarij
the khawarij are the first zealots
uh in islam who basically you know
thought that
uh not you know that ali and imam ali
and everyone else were not
you know true muslims and they were not
implementing islam as it is
so they rebelled against him um and they
wanted basically
they were just exactly like isis you
know bloodthirsty murdering creeps
um so imam ali adopted
a effective methodology with them
you first debate and then eradicate
the only way you can deal with them in a
war zone
in a civil society i would say
you first debate and then incarcerate
indefinitely because
without you know when imam ali debated
with them
one third of them basically just
recanted so they were admitted back into
society and the questions asked
the other two-thirds fought and they
were annihilated
and they were chased and killed in a war
zone
however in a civil society i would
advocate
that we debate powerfully we debate but
then
those who are not convinced keep them
locked up
until basically we see enough evidence
that they have
completely transformed themselves and
this could take years and years and
years
damon i have to say this appeals to my
russian heart very much
kill them all
but but i mean i'm sure you're a smart
man you appreciate
how difficult that sort of message is
politically for people to digest
um i'm surprised i didn't hear rory
stewart say that uh
but you know any politician who like
proactively advocates for that would be
absolutely destroyed can you imagine me
saying it with my voice
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
well this video is getting demonetized
right [ __ ] now
no no look i'm not advocating in
guantanamo i'm not advocating
you know particularly lucky that we have
to go unslaughter them if there is no
need in a war zone but i said in a war
zone of course basically your aim is to
you know eliminate your enemy but in a
civil society your aim is to keep the
society
safe and no one can say
that they know these people better than
we do
i don't take lectures from any
non-muslim non-arab academics or
political activists or journalists i
don't i take no lectures from them
you know these people are as dangerous
to our societies in the middle east as
well to our
societies here in europe as well as to
their own families sometimes we've seen
people when they return back to saudi
arabia murder their own cousins brothers
and fathers
and it happened and it's well documented
but amen i mean
part of the problem we're talking about
educating but
from what i remember one of the london
bridge um
terrorists was he was on a direct
accommodation read it
i'll repeat that he was on a
de-radicalization program was
he not on on the day that he killed
people
actually you see um
at that day i remembered i was
confronted in 2013
at the time i wasn't known to be you
know a former spy or anything but i was
confronted by
a well-meaning academic from oxford
uh she kept insisting basically that we
could
you know reach out to them we could
reach out to them you know you know
through
in a human connection and i keep saying
no
no no no because i know these people i
know you know how far they are
you know disconnected from their you
know human
links um and you know and then i said
i i smiled at her and i said the naivety
of the lambs
you know you know the silence of the
lambs the naivety of the lambs
i mean basically it's just you know the
lamb always think basically the human
you know basically oh he's we look he's
looking after me he's feeding me
oh look at the cute dog basically
shepherding me and then
one day of course basically uh they will
end up on the
shelves you know in pieces so you see
here
is the same thing it's it's the feeling
basically that
you are getting through to them but then
they surprise you by something like this
and it's not the first time not the
second time not the third time
it happened multiple times i mean i if
you watch the
uh film 0.30 uh
one of the agents a jordanian agent who
turned against the jordanian
intelligence and cia and basically he
was
he ended up basically just coming back
with a car
full of explosives and killed them all
killed the five handlers basically he
was dealing with
so it's not the first time that we see
this and this is why
uh the counter radicalization programs
uh as they call them cve counter
violence extremism
are riddled with naivetes and naive
ideals
um you know that secular
um you know principles you know liberal
democratic you know notions could
penetrate
into their minds nothing penetrates into
their minds
and actually convincing them soundly
that theologically and spiritually they
are on the wrong way
now amen so look uh it's quite a serious
thing that you're saying
uh and i'm sure you you you realize that
it is quite serious do you think
that essentially i mean it but it makes
sense at the same time because
if someone is willing to blow themselves
up or to stab
innocent people in the streets of london
i mean they're going to be pretty
extreme in their thinking i'd imagine
i'm not sure i've never been someone
who's who's done that but i imagine if
you were
for me to do that i'd have to be pretty
pretty extreme in my ways of thinking
i'm not sure i could be talked out of it
with some nice you know uh liberal
values or whatever um so do you think we
in the west have
this slightly idealized vision of human
beings now where we think
well human beings are all innately good
and fluffy and if we just talk to them
the right way they'll all behave
uh the way that we want and we're very
naive in that way
i think the reason because the west lost
touch generally with spirituality
they think basically you know on a
logical rational level
cynical i would say to the point of
cynicism
they don't believe that there are other
people who are deeply spiritual
you know deeply concerned more with the
afterlife than this life
and as a result you know they just don't
communicate on the same length in
wavelengths
they think that you know this is a human
so i can get to him through human
rational logical
arguments forgetting basically that that
other human basically is not on the same
wavelength as he is
and if you try to understand the world
through your own
cynical uh lack of spiritualism
then unfortunately you are going down a
rabbit hole and you can't find a way out
of it
um you know this is why whenever i talk
to people about prophecies and they say
oh
come on no no excuse me don't apply your
own
cynicism on you know situations that are
actually you know uh deeply spiritual
and deeply religious and superstitious
do not apply your own rational logical
thinking there
it's not going to work so for example
whenever i tell people that
you can't convince extremists the only
way you can get them
on the path of i'm not saying
theoreticalization i'm saying
disengagement from violence
that principle i believe in to disengage
from violence
you don't need to convince them you need
to confuse them
you need to sow the seeds of doubt in
their mind why
because you said how could someone
strap a bomb to themselves or take a
knife knowing
certainly they would be killed after
they stab few people by
police bullets how could they just do
that what
because they have a hundred percent
certainty
that the moment they you know
click that you know switch or when they
when when the bullets hit them that they
are going to end up in heaven they will
cross that
eternal bridge you know into the
afterlife
now if you upload
that little virus of doubt and just
create one or two or three percent of
that in their minds
then they will be transcending from
being certain
committed uh driven militants into
confused militants
and a confused militant will hesitate
and there has been
examples of people hesitating you know
and that hesitation was due to doubt
because of a statement they heard before
because of an argument with a friend or
a loved one before
so it happened and it's well documented
even
that they have basically stepped
backwards from killing
hundreds of people you know or dozens of
people i mean
in one incident basically it was someone
with a shoe bomb
about to board the plane and basically
he just went back home
hit the shoe under his bed and basically
didn't want to take part of it why
because
doubt due to statements he heard before
you know basically made him disengage
from that fatal moment he could have
killed
250 passengers so
it's you know this is why i don't
believe in the
radicalization i believe in um
basically what i call disengagement from
violence because these people will never
turn
into liberal democrats they know look
i'm still a conservative
you know i mean after all these years
you know
so i i voted boris twice in the london
mayoral elections
well eamonn you shouldn't have said that
mate the new story in the guardian
tomorrow is going to be former al-qaeda
operative comes out in support of boris
johnson
yeah they will remove the former spy
from my sex yeah
that's a former former terrorist
supports boris johnson that's it
but well so we've been talking about
this subject now for
and we could continue to explore it but
we're going to be moving on to something
that i think is
you have wanted to talk about and it's a
subject that has captured the minds and
hearts of people around the world which
is
the plight of the weaker muslims in
china now for those people who
may not be aware of what is happening
could you just give us a brief rundown
of what is going on in china at the
moment
if you try to imagine the chinese map
right now in your head and if you don't
basically just
pull up your smartphone you've got it
behind you mate
so if you if you look at the map of
china and you look at the northwest of
china there is a large province
that province is almost six times the
size seven times actually the size of
the united kingdom so it's
massive it's huge but it's really not
that much populated 35 million people i
think and roughly about between 13 to 15
million people of them are
uh from the ethnicity called the uyghurs
the uyghurs are
turkic people linguistically and
ethnically
they are quite close to the kazakhs
being people from kazakhstan kyrgyzstan
and they speak a language similar in
essence they are similar in names and
culture
so they've been part of china on and off
for almost 2000 years
so the land has been changing hands all
the time but
for the majority of that time basically
there were chinese province
sometimes basically vassal states
sometimes independent kingdom
and some you know and sometimes
basically it's their map is off and on
and you know to the sideways uh more
much more like the armenians poor
armenians so they're like scottish
people basically
[Applause]
uh given i live in scotland
i i i i wouldn't comment so
so basically the you know the weakest um
you know in recent years been subject to
intense
um i would say crackdown by the chinese
authorities
now um basically i must confess here
basically that i work
with many chinese oil companies and
telecommunication and
you know i you know i visit china
basically six seven times a year
uh i have many friends uh in beijing
both
uh from the private sector the public
sector uh from think tanks
including the confucius institute um
even in the jockey club of
the horse racing club there um so i
you know was always trying basically to
see the conflict there and i've been to
san juan before so i tried to
the province we were talking about where
the weakers are so i try to see the
conflict from both sides here
now it is important one of the things
that alarm me
alarmed me really in the last several
weeks is the fact that there
is a talk uh of a new jihad front
to be created in that part of the world
in the
chinese province of xinjiang known to
the locals as east turkestan as they
call it
turkestan in their local language
now not many people know that but if i
ask you um constantine if i ask you and
ask you thomas
what are the largest in which
nationality
constitute the largest jihadist
contingent in syria
well i mean i'm completely uneducated
guess
i would say somewhere i don't know like
iran
um okay uh constantine
are you gonna say like chechens or
something
well chechens formed about five thousand
i would say and they were
large uh for a while tunisians there
were about six
you know six thousand six thousand of
them
basically chinese citizens make up the
largest
contingent of jihadist foreign jihadists
in syria wow wow there are eight and a
half thousand of them
right now in idlib as well as
if we add the women and the children it
will be 21 000
in total they have a community of 21 000
and they are living in multiple villages
and towns
uh which used to belong to christians um
places like hellos and yakubiya and
genodea
and and they have populated these areas
now
there are eight and a half thousand
militants and these belong to a group
called
the tip or the turkistan islamic party
the turkistan islamic party was always
aligned with al-qaeda i knew them
basically since the days of afghanistan
when i was there
some of them were members of the
al-qaeda shura council
so they are extremely aligned to the
pride and while they are there actually
in
syria they are aligned uh not only to
uh hts which is uh you know
an offshoot of al-qaeda that is now more
independent
they are also allied to a group called
harassing
which is this official branch within
uh syria and also they have an
incredible
incredibly close relationship uh to the
turkish military intelligence and the
turkish intelligence
now the problem here is you know only in
recent
uh because of the chinese you know it's
it was like a self self-fulfilling
prophecy the chinese are always afraid
of tip
that they will come back and they will
carry out attacks and actually
some of the syrian returnees you know
people who returned from syria
to china committed in yunnan province
committed an act
of terrorism where in kunmin train
station
they took up knives basically and killed
47
people and wounded more than 140 others
so already there was you know acts of
terrorism taking place in china so since
2014 suddenly the
repression started they doubled down on
repression so the chinese reacted the
same way they always react
against any separatist movement whether
it is buddhists
in tibet or christians in the mainland
china or
against hong kong uh democracy uh
activists or against taiwan's aspiration
to be independent
they acted uh in that way but also
because
we have to understand also conflicts you
know from different angles here
you know there are two types of resource
conflicts you know there is resource
grab and there is resource protection
resource grab of course we know all
about it basically nations going into
other nations to try to grab
where experts are making our experts on
it
yeah um and there is
you know basically wars where people
trying to protect their own
resources uh for example look at the
kashmir
conflict it's about water you know there
are you know basically kashmir is where
the glaciers of india basically are
located
some of them and therefore basically the
water flowing from there is important
for india and they are not going to
concede that pakistan
no matter what just forget it the war
between saudi arabia
you know and yemen or between saudi
arabia and the houthis on the side of
the uh yemeni government
is about water security and the security
of the energy exports
uh and the food security in terms of
export and import
so you know people are vicious
you know look at these wars they are
vicious people are vicious
governments are vicious when they are
trying to protect their strategic
interests
sinjang province in the past it used to
be the back door of china but since
uh president xi ping decided that it's
going to be the new front door of china
that is going to be the place where you
know through it
the railways uh of the new silk road
the development initiative yeah yeah
it's going through because uh sinjung is
going to be
the junction where one part of the
railways will go through kazakhstan and
russia into
the heartlands of europe uh that will
take only 16 days for freight trains
as opposed to uh shipping through the
south china sea all the way to europe
through the sea
uh that takes 42 days so it is faster
cheaper less insurance and less
vulnerable to
a u.s blockade uh in the south china sea
um
so it is strategically important and the
second aspect of it
is the cpec or the china pakistan
economic corridor
which will take railways into uh
gwadar um in know port the waterport
basically is on the southern uh
shores of pakistan which will enable a
huge amount of trade
uh to go uh from china and into china
from the middle east especially the rich
arab gulf countries
now 12 million uighurs
will not stand you know basically you
know a chance against 1.4
billion chinese hands
and this is something that i want to you
know basically people to understand that
you know the focus you know in the past
several months about you know
encouraging and uprising
in xinjiang encouraging and i know
of certain forces you know secretly
working
to transport some of these militants
back to china to carry out
acts of terrorism too in the world of
some of these
you know agents to give china its own
afghanistan
is dangerous and i want to say to people
please
stop before it's too late because if you
try to create
a new afghanistan in china in that part
of the world
you will end up radicalizing
radicalizing thousands
of kazakhs of kyrgyz of uzbeks
of uh you know more afghans than
pakistan is going to join and then we
will end up basically seeing
european muslims and other middle
eastern muslims you know flying into
there and joining this
new jihad theater and it will be another
syria in the middle
of uh asia in a cynical way aim and i
can i can see why there are people in
in the west that might want that i mean
the way that you describe it but look
i i it's a very complicated situation i
guess what i'm hearing out of that
is essentially china sees this as a
trade route
uh area and it can't afford to have 12
million people running around stabbing
people or blowing [ __ ] up right that
would be the summary of it
yes but they are going about it the
wrong way because sure
i always look i always told my chinese
friends
what you're doing is making things
worse you know you know basically you
know the repression
is going to cause more and more you know
militancy but at the same time there are
other forces
who are stoking the fires of militancy
from abroad
you know it is becoming that the uyghurs
now are becoming the victim
of beijing and certain powers in certain
countries like turkey and the west
who are trying basically to uh give
china the headache in xinjiang in
retaliation for what you know
trade war coveted 19 you know hong kong
you know crisis i would say that
please we tried this in afghanistan we
tried this in syria and look what we are
doing right now look what
you know reward we are reaping right now
we are not supposed to encourage another
theater of jihad
what is the solution i know and this is
again what is the solution
the solution is not by adding sanctions
and pressure
the solution is by festering dialogue
the world weaker
congress you know i know that you know
they have leaders in the u.s like rabia
khadir i know they have
uh leaders in turkey like say it well if
say
is listening say it you invited me to
your home
in 2013 for iftar in ramadan you know i
have the greatest respect for you
all i can tell you and i can tell every
uyghur
the solution is in sitting down with
beijing
and entering into dialogue not
necessarily with the government but at
least
start with the academics start with with
the think tanks try to find the solution
to gain mostly you know try to find a
solution
to gain religious freedoms in exchange
for security
i think this is you know in my opinion
the best way
to go around it and not to encourage
militancy
the path that the tip the turkish
islamic party the al-qaeda aligned
tip is taking the uyghur cause
this on this path is going to lead to
nothing but destruction the chinese
you know the chinese juggernaut will do
will stop at nothing
they will basically take these 12
million and disperse them all over china
and replace them with hans that's what's
going to do i'm saying this because i
have fear
for them i feel for their culture i fear
for the survival
all i want them to do basically is to
just
stop take a breather and basically just
sit down with chinese academics
diplomats
reach out to their even to the chinese
private sector reach out to jack ma
even in the former ceo of alibaba you
know reach out to these people reach out
to saudi
uh diplomats reach out to uae diplomats
reach out basically to the think tanks
of the world
and try to arrange that kind of dialogue
at this low level to reach a higher
level later
to find a solution centering around
peace for religious freedoms
and i mean so you're appealing for for
them to be
peaceful can you because it still seems
vague to a lot of people
what is actually happening to these
people as we speak at the moment
what is the ccp and the army inflicting
upon them
as far as the chinese communist party is
concerned
you know they saw the problem of islam
in china that's how they see it that the
problem there
is mixture of islam and
uyghur separatism so they were saying
okay we don't have a problem with the
huey muslims
you know there are more human muslims
than weaker muslims in china by the way
so but relatively they are not harassed
as much as you know the uh
so they thought okay we have
the man who pacified tibet
you know we you know and modeled the
tibetan buddhism according to our
vision of china so how about
we model the uyghur islam
to to conform with the you know the
vision of the chinese communist nation
state
and so they sent the same man who was
the governor of tibet
to go and govern xinjiang and pacify it
the same way he did with it
with the tibetans also except that islam
is not buddhism
islam you know basically do contain
jihad
unlike buddhism so you know this is
where
amen are you saying not all religions
are the same
of course
whenever someone says to me basically
but even islam is a religion of peace
and i say please don't say it
you know it's this service to islam to
say islam is the religion of peace it's
not
you know basically islam is while it is
not inherently violent
it is basically a practical religion it
is a jihad
is the prerogative of the state it is
violent within a state structure
but peaceful within an individual
structure so it needs to be always
understood this way that it can deploy
violence if necessary
in a just cause but provided it's done
by a state
not by an individual only in the past 50
years
throughout islamic history we saw the
subversion of the right of the
state to deploy jihad and suddenly we
see individuals
like what happening in xinjiang and
syria you know
and kashmir places where individuals are
actually
deploying the uh deploying violence
deploying jihad
while it is not their right under
islamic theology the right to deploy
jihad is to the nation state then
what is happening the de legitimization
of the nation states
right we come back to the beginning yes
so take us through so take us back to
the uyghurs in in
in this province uh they they bring this
government
who who treats it like he treated the
buddhists in tibet
and then what happens and then that's it
you know okay so we have to re-educate
them all
you know so take them into these camps
and basically turn you know make them
sing the national and
everyday read the mao uh red book every
day
tell them about marx you know theory
theories every day even though
in the chinese economy unmarks are you
know basically
uh balls apart um and then feed them
you know basically the love and
um loyalty to the nation states in china
but the problem is that they are going
about it basically the same way they
always do with everything else the
industrial way
you know it's just industrial is that
that's how they understand it
because they are not you know deeply
religious
people they they they be that they are
you know
it's they are a little bit of luck in an
enigma you know basically they are
communist
in their thinking but they are also
capitalist consumers in their
uh practice in their daily lives you
know and
you know and because of of course
basically the normal relations of
brotherly hood
or brotherhood basically and sisterhood
has been uh you know more or less
dismantled over the past generation or
two because of the one child policy so
you end up basically with
more and more selfish generations you
know being born who don't understand
basically the collective will of the
weakest by the way the weakest were
always allowed
as a religious minority to have more
than two or three children
uh not many people know that in one you
know some of the minorities were allowed
to do that
um and they were always represented as
one of the minorities of
um uh china in fact if you take a
chinese currency
there are four uh scripts on it so there
are four
uh calligraphy chinese calligraphy
uh mongolian calligraphy tibetan
calligraphy
and uh uyghur calligraphy so it's all
represented in the chinese currency
but it's the industrial way
of you know okay we have a problem so
what do we do basically
okay take the millions and put them in
the in the camps
when the split between the soviet union
and
china happened and the soviet union
decided to
pull away the nuclear program assistance
for china
you know the russian engineers before
they left they shredded
you know the nuclear program documents
and left
but the chinese gathered you know the
eight million pieces
you know in the 1960s they gathered the
eight million pieces of shreds
and employed one million chinese to put
them together in the biggest
holy [ __ ] and that's how china have a
nuclear power
nuclear bomb so it's the industrial
mindset
so right it's cve or counter violent
extremism
in an industry on an industrial scale
they deal with
it okay if you tell the chinese this is
a knot
forget basically a sledgehammer they
will bring
you know a bulldozer you know basically
with this knot
so we have you know because why for them
they see
thin junk as you know their achilles
here their vulnerability their buffer
zone being
you know basically a subject of a
conspiracy you know internally and
externally
so the paranoia takes in the industrial
repression mindset takes
you know you know takes hold and they
move in
uh in this way now uh this is why i'm
saying
that the only solution for this is
dialogue only you know the repression
will continue unfortunately
until there is a dialogue that
guarantees for china as security and
guarantees for the weakest their
religious freedoms
well i mean that is incredibly bleak
amen i mean because we know that with
china
uh when it comes to human rights whether
it's tibet whether it's hong kong i
think it's been fair to say that that's
they're not that's not one of their
strong points is it really
indeed but the solution is not to create
another afghanistan that will
suck in thousands upon thousands of
young muslims from the west from the
middle east
from uh south asia from central asia
and also this will impact russian uh
security it will impact on the security
of the central asian republics
it will impact the security of india to
impact the security of pakistan
we don't want that please amen how close
are we to that situation happening do
you think how close are we to that the
catastrophic event
i think we will see it in 2021 wow
if we if those who are planning it
and i know who they are if those who are
planning it
do not basically put the you know uh hit
the post button right now
and understand that they're playing with
fire
and how much truth is there to some of
the things that we're hearing out of
china
you you talk about this industrial
approach essentially where
you know human beings are cogs in a
machine uh much more than they are
uh individuals to to be looked after and
thought of
as as people um what a you know
how much do there is is there to you
know concentration camps we see these
images of people with shaved heads we
read stories about
exports of human hair going to the
united states
from china we we hear forced
sterilization programs we hear
forced organ organ donations all of this
stuff
right like to to people in the west
that sounds pretty horrific and because
because it is is
is all of that true is that happening
all i can tell you is that in regard to
the concentration comes they are true
i mean basically uh they are but however
we're not talking about people basically
staying there forever the
people staying there between an average
of eight months you know and then they
so-called graduate whether that's true
or not i don't know
all i know is i shouldn't laugh but it's
just crazy man
the average is eight months either
before basically they are released back
into society
um and you know if you drive through
xinjiang you will find there are some
towns that are empty and there are some
towns that are
completely bustling full and thriving uh
the towns that are empty
are the towns that you know basically
they suspect of being rebellious and the
towns that are
thriving are the muslim towns they
suspect of or they are absolutely sure
they are
uh loyal and cooperative it seems that
the chinese are dividing the uyghurs
into
you're loyal you're not you know uh we
trust you
we don't you know so it seems to me
basically that
the uh you know they are the prison
camps basically they are
exactly what they are prison camps but
they are no different from what you see
from the rest of china
because even in the rest of china they
make people even write postcards
they print postcards they make people
basically in a work on
uh you know producing uh goods and
services and toys even
there are toy factories that actually
prisons you know in many of the toys
basically that you see sometime on the
shelves
were made there by prisoners because
prisoners need to work in order to earn
you know their living which is not not
far away from what is practiced in the
united states actually in some prisons
where
you know uh you know if you call you
know the hotline
you know basically to order a pizza in
the most likely the one processing
order is a prisoner in a prison call
center
it had happened in the u.s so it is
happening already in china
china have you know basically this huge
efficiency of
you are in prison we can achieve your
hair use your hair you know for whatever
we want
if you die in prison you know you are uh
organ donor you know straight away if
you know basically we uh and whatever
you work for
yes we're gonna sell it abroad or enter
in the
internal market however you know this is
what you are going to uh
spend we give you the money in the
prison to spend on toothpaste and
toothbrush
and extra food and pen and paper and
books basically you want to read
so it is a brutal prison system but
it is not that much different from what
you see in the u.s
in some states wow
i mean the thing is
it's taken my breath away a little bit
amen what you've just been talking about
everything from
afghanistan and to iraq to you know the
treatment of the uyghurs
and i i think one question that we're
all probably wondering is what what can
we do is there anything we can do in the
west
is there any particular organizations
who are trying to
represent the uyghurs maybe trying to
help or ease their plight in some way
shape or form
i think foreign ministries
in the west should be in touch with the
world uighur congress
especially their leadership in turkey
they are more powerful than their
leadership in the us
and try to you know basically
find a way to
both put the pressure on the wall with
the congress and on the chinese
government to actually sit down together
and work out a solution to this crisis
because this cannot go forward also i
really
really wish if the two most powerful
uh men in the arab world i'm talking
here
you know to the crown prince of saudi
arabia prince mohammed bin salman and to
the crown prince of the
uh abu dhabi um
we've got a big audience but i'm not
sure those two are watching right now
[Laughter]
but they have a incredible clout with
china
they could basically also find a way
to you know basically bridge the gap
between the two the problem is
the cause of the uyghurs has been
hijacked especially by the muslim
brotherhood and by
the turkish government in particular
which doesn't see eye to eye
with the two people i just you know
mentioned the
leaders of saudi arabia and the uae
so unfortunately the muslim and arab
world are so divided even basically to
find any
meaningful support for the weakest and
therefore basically the best way to do
it
is to you know organizations like the
european institute for peace
the iep you know institutions like the
eu for example
institutions like the united nations
these institutions they can
find a way to bridge the gap at least
start
at an academic level you know uh you
know if there is a
there is a there is a film called the
end game uh
which william hurt and um you know other
you know amazing stars um you know in
2009 came together to
create this film about how you know
basically
a you know an employee from a gold
company
in the uk based in london was the spark
in the mid 1980s to make
some you know academics white academics
in south africa sit down with
anc officials in london in a house in
somerset
to for four years in dialogue which
resulted in
finally the release of nelson mandela
and the start of the
handover of the uh or the dismantling of
the apartheid
uh and the democratic elections in south
africa so
you know it all started at an academic
level so if we could basically get
academics you know from both sides
chinese academics and uighur academics
to sit down together in neutral
locations
you know in malaysia in singapore
[Music]
you know in switzerland if we could in
norway if we could get
could get them to sit down together and
talk about
you know how can they basically manage
each other's expectations you know bring
down the demands
slowly slowly gradually basically until
there is a common ground
once there is a common ground then you
know things could start to translate
into officials
sitting together and the end result
would be restoration of some degree of
autonomy
religious freedoms in exchange for
security stability and loyalty to
uh the beijing government if that were
to happen and of course basically then
the weakest will share in the prosperity
that awaits
you know the xinjiang province as a
whole because of the
uh massive investment in the silk road
uh
projects in more than 900 billion
dollars are being
poured into that particular project so
the weakest could become basically
the ambassador the chinese ambassadors
to the muslim world
instead of being you know the
enemy within that the chinese basically
perceived them to be
well that makes a lot of sense and i do
hope mohammed ben salman was listening
and
he's going to take your advice uh even
but and also mate if you are listening
sing us a couple of quid right
looking for a new studio yeah sign up to
the patreon mates
that's what we want mbs on our patreon
that would be terrific top dog patron
mate only 200 bucks a month come on you
can afford it you can afford a mate
we'll even meet with you and have a meal
with you for two
dollars don't pick up the check from the
consulate
uh but even listen it's been absolutely
fantastic talking to you it's been a
long time in the making both you and
thomas of the conflicted podcasts are
some of our favorite guests
i'm sure we will be having you back to
talk about other things
as they happen but before we let you go
we've got one more question for you
which is the question that we always ask
at the end
which is what is the one thing that
we're not talking about
as a society that we really should be
the nation states just
the crisis of the nation state is
affecting ev you know everyone basically
it's not just only an islamist
you know uh desire to bring down the
nation state now
unfortunately we start to see our young
in the west
turning their back on the nation state
the only
you know model to guarantee safety
security stability prosperity law and
order everything we take for granted
they haven't seen you know how what
collapsed
societies look like you know and how
people
you know they are desperate for things
we take for granted here
right now so you know we have to fight
for the nation state and make the case
again for the nation state
i couldn't agree with you more i could
not agree more even if people want to
follow your work
where do they go to listen to conflicted
and any other things that you
you are doing well for now i'm doing
conflicted um and if they want to you
know read more about my life basically
my book is out there
uh my life as in mi6 spy inside the card
fantastic guys make sure you check both
of those out the conflicted is probably
the best
the best podcast after trigonometry
obviously
that i've ever listened to it's really
really brilliant
uh so make sure you check it out thank
you for watching eamon thank you for
joining us
very much and we'll see you all very
soon with another
brilliant episode like this or a live
stream and please remember guys that uh
episodes and live streams always go out
at 7 p.m uk time
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word